what is happening there reject nation we
finally got ourselves a moon night
official trailer coijondro back on the
channel i'm here i'm alive i'm excited
our marvel comics expert right here
we're counting on you to give a the best
trailer review afterwards luckily moon
knight isn't dense or complicated or has
gone through a series of cancellations
and myriad of writers it's a very linear
character easy to explain all right you
have to wrap it up in like two minutes
two minutes whole character
watch time to worry about it right
i know my place this is content all
right we talk slowly and calmly there's
only so much we can learn on wikipedia
before filming as you guys know i love
wikipedia hosts
[Music]
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
[Music]
i'm looking forward to this already
yes
[Music]
you're bloody useless
stevie stephen
[Music]
hope you find it
thanks
oh my god you're alive what's wrong with
you mark
why did you call me mark
that's your stance that's difficult
oh it's in your head
[Music]
this
[Music]
wow
um
shadow of the moon night
how nice
i love how they even change their colors
to it
you know man uh is it this is the shadow
of moon knight did you catch like there
was he walked under the light and the
the crescent moon like that's oh that's
my that's one of my favorite ones from
any trailer this this uh this is is it
too early to say that this might turn
into my favorite one of the marvel
that's not just me like talking hype
that is that is like oh my god that is
exactly my kind of show right there i
think that's the best trailer the
darkness the supernatural elements the
variety of performance by oscar isaac
because yeah this confirms that he is
going to be we were like speculating
before the trailer started of will they
get like different actors for some of
the personalities which one seems to be
the dominant personality though in this
trailer there seems to be one stephen
scene dominant
but i think that's a mislead because
mark is in the comic book is the
dominant one mercenary that gets taken
out by bushmaster yes and i assume
that's a mislead on purpose because it's
not a known character so maybe steven is
who we identify with in the first
episode yeah and therefore you think
he's this more posh well-to-do guy and
then maybe the second episode they
introduced the cabbie and we've got a
character you're like wait why is he now
this guy and like we slowly find mark
maybe like uncover his true self yeah
what i'm loving about it is like how
psychological it is like it's gonna deal
with the fact of how this kind of plays
on uh disassociative identity disorder
and the way how they visually represent
that through like the cracks and the
mirrors and the different
presences and the hallways and stuff
like that was so cool to behold and
oscar i think the cadence like that the
flavor of the edit which i hope the show
follows with man john what was your
favorite part about it oh man just the
the whole vibe and atmosphere really i
mean i like that this movie this trailer
played more like a movie trailer than a
tv show trailer and you know it is a six
episode contained series with the option
of going beyond that and i think that
this is the perfect way to just hook
everybody for yeah the kind of ride
we're into it looks like the kind of
thing that's going to be very fraught
and very paranoid and i love anything
that has that quality where you know
you've got flashes and echoes and what's
real which reflection is actually mine
you know ethan hawk looks
sinister as you know i wonder if he's
conscious
himself no no like like a i i said
country but someone working directly for
him like the voice of country like he's
okay
i don't think he's the actual god but
explain that a little bit for them so
basically mark spector is killed in an
incident as a mercenary xcia and he is
dragged into an egyptian temple where he
isn't actually alive or dead he's
basically revived in what he thinks is
serving the god of konchu he is the
moon's knight which is the egyptian god
of the night and basically the powers he
has yeah
and that's the difference between him in
batman so like batman is striking fear
because he wants to avenge his parents
he's in love with the concept of
vengeance so it's not about a specific
vengeance it's vengeance incarnate which
is what makes this character so
interesting he wears white as a threat
he wants you to see him he believes in
hurting those that deserve it and it's
unilateral it's anyone that deserves it
so he's striking fear for this god and
he doesn't really have a power set like
in some continuities as the moon wanes
some of his powers increase like if
there are some moon thailands i don't
know if they're going to do that but
konshu himself is a voice that speaks to
him and there's some continuities where
the voices in his head are catalyzed by
khanshu there's also some where konju
saw him as a young child wait until he
was old enough and then made him his
mercenary like it was all faded i don't
know which ones are gonna know i'm
assuming they'll do the one where it's
later in life he gets activated that
causes the voices to materialize there's
two main voices and then there's two
supporting voices um there's the inner
child and the uh mr knight which i think
will come in later and then there's jake
as well as stephen and i think we're
gonna get those very early on like i
said i think mark will be uh developed
the main
human self will come i don't know if
anything that made sense i think
i know i i know the anxiety of like
because i'm very interested as i was
catching we've done more than wikipedia
like i was catching on to let's catch up
where you're saying you said conscious
i'm like okay there might be some people
who don't know what's going on they're
like we got all this egyptian imagery in
here it looks like like the trailer
might have you believing that he gets it
like at the museum artifact spot but you
see i think you see a pyramid at one
point it was kind of moving by fast so i
imagine that his personality was
eventually at one point in egypt and
then he's probably just going to like
here are some authentic artifacts at
this museum that are being called to me
in some ways right like some people when
the teaser trailer came out what do you
think some people were saying that looks
like a werewolf some people were saying
looks like anubis i mean they've said
that egyptology is going to be a big
part of the show and so in that breath i
would imagine maybe something like that
but moon knight's origin also ties in
with the werewolf by night which i would
just be so excited to see them breach
further into especially because this is
also being billed as a scarier more
horror-centric series so i mean for for
my geeky heart i would be thrilled by
that although something a little more
egyptian would fit as well you know what
i really thought with ethan hawk it's
not exactly the same thing there were
vibes about parts of this trailer that
were making me reminisce on the first
blade movie
and steven dorff's like the the
villainous president that he had there
there was parts about ethan hawk that i
was thinking of i say that complimentary
wise his blade that is like i actually i
love that first movie started marvel and
then you know we were thinking about the
future of like a darker avengers set
like the midnight suns and having blade
possibly come into the mix here and
maybe blade might cap like he had a
voiceover cameo in eternals post credit
scene spoilers by the way sorry i don't
give a heads up but yeah yeah that came
in here and i was like it would make
more sense for even blaze to appear here
if they're like teasing his appearances
as guest starring how neat would that be
in the revived term i could totally see
blade guest starring in this show and
spoilers for no way home daredevil also
allows this could set the precedent for
a dark show to allow daredevil to be as
dark since it is canon to the netflix
show which is much darker than the mcu
this would allow that universe to exist
alongside the mcu you can do a marvelous
you can do something with daredevil like
that more ultra violence that's one of
the things i was really gravitated
towards about this trailer was when
you're hearing moon knight when you're
learning about him you're like wow this
sounds like this would have to be a
really dark almost like closer to the
netflix shows than any of the other
disney plush shows that we've gone in so
far other than some you know certain
shots that look really pop in the colors
in that mcu fashion for the most part
the tone the mood the atmosphere of it i
want to get a better sense of the
atmosphere honestly because i'm like we
got like that cool music that i thought
complemented the trailer well but i do
want to get a better sense of like what
will some of these scenes feel like and
so far i'm loving it can i say like the
directing in this uh two of my buddies i
love these guys to death justin and
aaron are are two of the best directors
working and i'm honored to call them
friends they make that's the only reason
you're recommending this i'm yes i'm
only here for them so uh if you haven't
seen spring if you haven't seen
synchronics if you haven't seen the
endless check out their work the reason
i think they suit this so well is they
do this insane existential pondering
this otherworldly this this atmospheric
tone that's going to suit this so well
they're like hp lovecraft vibes that i
think are going to really tie into how
this mythology looks visually yeah and
both of these guys are they've done
everything on a set they've done every
single job on the set and now they're
directing one of the coolest most hard
to discern characters so these guys are
going to be so hands on they're going to
make this their own and that's why i
think this looks so unique is justin and
aaron are geniuses and this is going to
show for it so uh can we have them on
the channel for an interview i mean
we'll send them this link we'll be like
hey justin here
yeah if they're your real friends
they'll text them watch this video and
then they'll that's true we'll test that
yeah we'll see if that's one way if you
retweet this director's a moon
great guys i love you guys no pressure
i'm not
no all right intimidated
well we're done here we're styling i
think that was your name yeah it was
because if you've seen spring the
endless or synchronic which i recommend
you do in fact homework if you want to
understand moon knight check out their
work also check out the mirror's run the
ellis run bendis's runs and cabbage's
art any of that stuff to give you the
flavor of this book
you know
you don't have to feed the whole cattle
of all the time
it's been around since the 70s i gave
the taste it's a dump of information
jeff lemire subscribe if you're
interested
you can leave your thoughts down below
follow coy because he knows crap some
more comics uh look guys we'll see you
soon